do you think is it realistic that you
could even have retaken Crimea by
January
you know there is a phenomenon called
Black Swan
so unexpected event
coming to calculations nobody expected
it to come
so I think
Russia can face a Black Swan in in the
country inside in Russia
and it can contribute to the success of
us with Crimea
they are also a military option as well
with some kind of combination of forces
resources and something else we can step
in Crimea for example
by the end of December
possible possible
not excluded if it would be so and can
you just explain a bit more what kind of
Black Swan event could happen in the
next two or three months in Russia
Putin disappeared
for example due to some reason
or physical or political for example or
somebody from his Circle
something happened
or maybe a combination of very
disillusioned Society in terms of their
losses when do you negotiate with with
Russia
negotiate with Russia only when they are
ready to leave our territories could it
be finished before the 24th of February
I think being realistic we issued as a
military as a military
to you
[Music]
to follow this scenario that
we will need some time to build up some
kind of reserves or something and also
that you Russia will continue to send
massive people there
and of course in this case the war will
take some time
but my feeling is that by the end of the
spring
this war will over
will over
by the end of the spring yes